over the last few weeks we've seen major
new releases for both angular and
firebase and that has resulted in
angularfire version 5.2 and it contains
a whole bunch of new features that you
may have not been expecting in today's
video we'll look at five brand new
features in angular fire and how they
can help simplify your angular firebase
project if you're new here like and
subscribe and you can find the full
write-up on fire ship IO the first new
feature you should be aware of are the
new schematics that make it easy to add
angular fire to an existing project and
then deploy it to firebase hosting all
we have to do is run ng add angular fire
and then select a corresponding firebase
project that will install the necessary
dependencies and also initialize
firebase in this project and another
cool thing is that it hooks into the new
builder API at angular 8 which allows us
to run a command to deploy this project
to firebase hosting in other words you
can go from zero to a deployed app with
just two commands the next new feature
you should be aware of is the
integration of firebase performance I
already have an entire video on this
topic and adding firebase perf to your
project is pretty much a no-brainer but
angular fire is not just a wrapper for
performance it extends it with
additional functionality specifically
for rxjs you can get basic performance
reporting with a single line of code or
you can use one of the custom rxjs
operators to run a manual trace this
makes it really easy to measure the
performance of things like HTTP calls
because all you have to do is pipe in
this custom operator and everything else
happens for you automatically the third
new feature is my favorite and that's
because I wrote the code for it and it's
just a new option on value changes when
listening to the value of a document or
collection the option is called ID field
and it allows you to return the document
ID in addition to the document data when
working with firestore you often need
the document data to show in the UI and
then you need the ID itself to make
updates or rights to the database but
combining the document ID with the data
is an overly complex process in my
opinion value changes returns an
observable that emits a JavaScript
object or an array of objects the ID
field argument is optional and it will
return the document ID map to a specific
property on the object so this allows
you to specify the property name for the
ID so you don't accidentally overwrite
some underlying data that's already on
the document so the end result is less
complexity and fewer lines of code in
your front-end applications now the next
feature that we'll look at is the
collection group query
which is new and firebase version six
this feature is also covered in detail
in its own video but it's something you
should definitely be aware of because it
adds a ton of flexibility to data
modeling and firestore in angular fire
the usage looks like this where we have
a reference to a collection group that
will group all the collections in the
database with that same name making it
possible to run queries across all the
data contained in all the sub
collections with that same name now I
save the best for last and that is the
angular fire auth card module if you've
ever built something like role based
authorization in an angular firebase app
there's a good chance that you have a
lot of complex code living in your
router guards apps that have a lot of
custom authorization logic typically
need to lock down specific routes based
on a user's role or authorization level
the most simple use case is when you
want to lock down a route based on
whether or not a user is logged in we
can now easily handle that logic by
simply dropping in the angularfire auth
guards you can activate on the routes
that we want to apply it to but what if
we want to redirect the user to the
login page
if this guard results to false the guard
module provides they can activate helper
method that allows us to pass in a
custom rxjs operator and there's a bunch
of built-in operators for the most
common situations like redirecting an
unauthorized user to a different route
and you can even do the opposite of
redirecting a logged in user to a new
route and if the built-in functions
aren't enough for you you can actually
build your own because they're just
custom rxjs operators under the hood and
a custom rxjs operator is just a
JavaScript function we'll go ahead and
create our own auth pipe which is a
function that should return an
observable of a boolean or an array of
strings if we want to redirect the user
to a new route we can easily do this by
using the rxjs map operator and its
callback function will give us access to
the firebase user which we can use to
determine whether or not this user is
authorized to visit this route for the
Jeff guard we're going to make sure that
the users display name contains the
substring of Jeff and now we can use
this logic by simply combining it with
the can activate helper so over all the
auth guard module provides a much
simpler and concise way to write
authorization logic with the angular
router in most cases all the hard work
will be done for you but if you want to
implement your own custom logic it's
just a matter of writing a function over
all angular version 5.2 adds a ton of
new functionality and does a lot of
things to help simplify your code I'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
if this video helped you please
I can subscribe and consider becoming a
pro member at fire ship IO to get access
to even more content thanks for watching
and I will talk to you soon
[Music]